Let's discuss the solution to our BTB and BHT
quiz. We have a BHT that has 16 entries and
it's a 1-bit predictor. Each of the entries is a
single bit that tells us what the last outcome was.
And initially they start off at predicting, not-taken. The
question was, how many mispredictions do we have for each
instruction? Initially the BHT says not-taken for all of the
entries and we have already seen that the BHT entry
that we will use are all different. So these
branches any other instructions are not going to interfere with
each other. Each of them just uses its own
BHT entry, because the initial prediction is not-taken. And
this is indeed not a taken branch. We have
0 missed predictions here, same here. When we enter
the loop, this branch is actually not-taken, so we
have no missed prediction the first time we execute it.
This instruction here is predicted not-taken the first
time. It's not-taken for real, so every other time
that we execute it it's going to be predicted
not-taken correctly, so there is 0 mispredictions. And same
thing happens here, and here, and here. For
this branch, things are more interesting. The initial prediction
in the BHD is going to be not-taken, but
this branch is taken, so we have a misprediction
the first time this branch is taken. Then,
the BHT entry for that instruction is updated to
say taken, so every other time that we execute
this instruction it's correctly predicted as taken. So we
have only the one misprediction initially. For this
branch, it's never taken until the very last time,
the 101st time we do it. Every time it's
not-taken, we have a correct prediction, because we start
out in the not-taken state of the predictor, and
just keep doing that. The last time we need
to execute this branch, it is taken. And the
last outcome that we have seen was not-taken. So
there will be again a single misprediction here. So
as you can see the 1-bit predictor is very
accurate. We are executing a lot of instructions. This
one is done a 101 times, this one is done
a 100 times, these are done a 100 times each. So, for what amounts to more than
600 instruction executions, we only have two mispredictions. This
shows that the 1-bit predictor really works well for
things like loops that execute many iterations. However,
we will see later that it doesn't work well
for some of the other things like, for example,
loops don't have many iterations or if then analysis